[Music]
i just want to clarify some things
before we
before we get started
every woman is not built for the great
responsibility of being the first lady
pastor lee curtis childs faces
allegations of misconduct
his mega church may never be the same
lee curtis and i we're going to get to
the other side
hear that yeah with a big old microphone
come in closer son you gonna see what
all the fuss is about
showtime what's up fresh is our turn
baby
lee curtis is a talent a star oh boy uh
we can edit around that
right this is going to chronicle the
ultimate comeback
i'm rocky up in this fight
rocky didn't win but he did win in rocky
too
lord baby how many times i got to tell
you get past the first movie that was
all set up
[Music]
don't bless your heart i'm sure plenty
of the old congregation will come right
on back through good old wands of the
greater pets to us
you have a blessed one oh my goodness
and you have a bless
i'm a center but i'm no criminal we need
you back in that pulpit
so you can get me back on that stage
you ain't really getting that many
graves baby
shake it for the lord
shake it for the lord
[Music]
[Applause]
all those folks out there who are gonna
see this
i want them to know
that i did what i was supposed to do
i just don't see how that's possible all
things are possible with god that's
matthew 19 20. yes it is
so that's
[Music]
in good and streaming only on peacock
september 2nd
[Music]
you